well it looks like we're not done with
the Illuminati in the MCU however this
Illuminati that we are about to see show
up in our 616 universe is going to be
different than what we've seen so far in
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness but it looks like we know a few
of the members already and they might be
what you think but some also might not
be what you think what is going on
everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder I'm Warren Thompson and a
combination of a couple of reports over
the week we give us a good idea of who
the members of our new Illuminati in the
earth 616 Universe are going to be it
also might give us a little bit of a
hint of which characters could possibly
be saved in our universe if our universe
does indeed suffer from an incursion and
gets destroyed we've heard that TVA is
going to go across the Multiverse saving
certain heroes from destruction could
our universe face that fate and is that
where the new Illuminati comes in now
one of the most most interesting Parts
about these reports is that the Scarlet
Witch is reportedly going to be a member
of the new Illuminati team now this
makes sense as far as strengthwise and
powerwise as of right now you would
argue that she is the strongest person
that exists right now in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe she wiped the floor
with the other Illuminati from the 838
Universe however here's where it gets
kind of interesting another reported
member of the Illuminati is supposed to
be W and I'm sure right now Wong does
not have the best of feelings for the
Scarlet Witch she killed a lot of people
including a lot of his apprentices and
other fellow Sorcerers and not to
mention who we also think was his lover
although Madison is in the equation now
so perhaps he's moved on to someone new
but main point being obviously Wong is
not going to have the best of feelings
for the Scarlet Witch right now however
he might not really have a choice in the
face of a multiversal collapse and the
destruction of the entire Multiverse
being at stake here he'll probably have
to admit that they're going to need the
Scarlet Witch to help now this report is
coming from The Insider my time to shine
hello who is stating that Wanda is going
to be the surprise member of the earth
616 Illuminati so first and foremost
let's not confuse this with the other
Wanda from the 838 Universe because
there have been reports that that
Illuminati team the ones that are still
alive could possibly form a new team and
seek revenge on our Wanda According to
some insiders there was another person
of the Illuminati that was not present
that day and this person is the person
in that universe who created those
Ultron Bots that we saw so a lot of
people are assuming Tony Stark Iron Man
so that separate story might come to
fruition eventually and they might use
the Wanda of the 838 Universe to join
their Illuminati team however we are
specifically talking about a 616
Illuminati team so not a variant of
Wanda but the Wanda the Scarlet Witch
that we know from W vision from Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
it's going to be her and according to
The Insider can we get some toast the
other members of the Illuminati Earth
616 team for now are going to be Wong
Captain Marvel and Bruce Banner slth
Hulk now this is a very interesting team
however it is made up of what you could
argue to be the most powerful characters
on Earth presuming Captain Marvel comes
back to Earth in the Marvels and stays
on Earth but as it turns out that scene
at the end of shanqin The Legend of the
10 Rings could have actually been an
illumin Scene It was Wong communicating
with his fellow Illuminati members
Captain Marvel and Breece Banner sort of
a possible threat that he just came upon
the 10 rings that shanqi had and this
team makes sense Bruce Banner is a
genius Captain Marvel is incredibly
powerful and she is not on Earth she's
located in the cosmos pretty much
everywhere out there in our universe and
Wong right now is the current sorcerer
Supreme now you might be wondering about
Doctor Strange well at this point in
time I do believe that he's kind of
going to be off planet in a sense sense
that he's going to be in Another
Universe because he's going to be with
Clea helping her fix an incursion that
he caused just like it was explained at
the end in the post credit scene for
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness but here's the deal once Kang
comes and everything kind of falls apart
I don't think this team is really going
to one stay together or two keep only
these members of the team of what we've
been hearing recently about Deadpool 3
and Avenger Secret Wars is true then
this team is going to be incredibly
important and it's going to get bigger
one of of the reports that we've heard
recently is that there is indeed going
to be a sort of multiversal Avengers
team and this team could be the main
team in secret Wars that goes on to take
on King the Conqueror and of course all
of his variants however a big question
Still Remains right now and that is Does
our universe the 616 Universe get
destroyed one of the reports states that
in Deadpool 3 the TVA is going to go to
a bunch of different universes that are
dying they're going to save some heroes
from those universes and bring bring
them back to kind of one shared Universe
where a bunch of people who have been
saved are now going to share is our
universe one of those universes that
gets destroyed that's a pretty big
question that we don't know right now we
do know that there is going to be
somewhat of an incursion in the Marvels
we're not sure if they're going to fix
it but we do know that it's going to
start to happen in the Marvels we also
know that the Marvels is kind of going
to lead into King Dynasty and the King
Dynasty is where incursions could really
start to happen specifically for our
universe so there of course is the
possibility that Deadpool or Mobius or
whoever from the TVA pops up and says
hey we got to go and if that happens at
that point who would they probably pick
well if the Earth had a illuminati team
a team that consisted of the most
powerful heroes from our universe
especially if that team was established
as an actual team who protects not only
the Earth but the entire universe well
that's probably who the TVA would pick
and if the MCU really is going to do a
soft reboot then we could kind of assume
that the Illuminati team is basically
going to consist of the characters that
Kevin fogy wants to keep around in the
new universe following the reboot but we
don't really know what that's going to
be like we don't know if the 616
universe is going to be completely
destroyed and if it is destroyed we
don't know if they're going to somehow
bring it back but if they don't then the
Illuminati should consist of characters
like Spider-Man Miss Marvel the new
Fantastic 4 team who I am assuming is
eventually going to join a multiversal
illuminati team basically any characters
who should be a part of phase S phase 8
phase 9 and so on and so forth should
make it but unfortunately right now we
don't really know what the ending is we
don't know what's going to happen to the
616 universe so that part is a little
bit up in the air right now also we're
not sure if this is going to tie into
the Iron Man 2 Illuminati Easter egg
this was back in 2010 in Iron Man 2 Iron
man pulls out his phone and he has an
app on it titled the Illuminati it even
has the same logo that the comic book
book Illuminati team has and we've never
really gotten any answers about this was
this just a little Easter egg that
Marvel Studios included in there just a
little something for the fans who knew
what the Illuminati was or was this
something Tony Stark was actually doing
was he building an Illuminati team or
was there one that had already existed
that recruited him perhaps this might
finally give us an answer to that in a
universe where everything is connected
you'd like to believe that they were
indeed building a team however it was
such a long time ago in a very early
phase of the MCU it might not have had
any connectivity to future plans moving
forward in the MCU and could have just
been a little nice Easter egg either way
an Illuminati team is coming to the MCU
and the Scarlet Witch should be
returning to be a part of that team so
let me know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below are you excited
for this are you not excited for this
and let me know who you think should be
a part of the 616 Illuminati team
besides who we've already mentioned
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news and if you subscribe
and leave a comment M you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
woof